our people deserve a pay rise they've
been working throughout the pandemic
just like everyone else in the economy
they haven't had a pay rise in three
years
and workers in general in this country
have seen their wages falling as a share
of wealth crate for about 40 years so I
think everyone in the country needs a
pay rise and deserves a pay rise and so
do our members
do you accept that the service that's
being provided by the rail service at
the moment is not satisfactory and to
what end do you accept that that is the
responsibility of your members well it's
not the responsibility of my members our
members run the railway the
responsibility sits with a department
for transport who sets it up so we've
had privatization which has been a
disaster in this country we've had
fragmentation which has been a disaster
we've got private companies ripping the
British traveling public off and we've
had that for years and that's not down
to people who work on the railway we're
the people that keep the trains moving
and look after people when they're
traveling it's a matter for government
and the people who run the railway to
set that up in the right way and I've
made a dog's breakfast a book so they
can't run the services when we're not on
strike never mind when we are on strike
yeah you're also responsible you are
also the people that stop the rail
service running and you're going to do
that over several days 48-hour periods
over the next before and after Christmas
how do you justify that or quite simply
um we have got a situation where
billions are being taken out of the
operational expenditure for the railway
uh thousands of jobs are being slashed
safety schedules are being cut in half
we're seeing the private companies uh
creaming off profits in the industry
laughing all the way to bank and we're
being told that our members have got to
have a pay freeze that's not justified
so if it were well justified in taking
strike action let's try and improve that
situation